Playing with picture objects in BlueJ is kind of fun. Let me make a couple of
picture objects. If you look carefully how I constructed the last object, I
filled in the name of the file here. And I'll do it one more time like that. If
you do it in this way, you also have to tell the program to draw the objects by
selecting the draw method. The first picture appears, and a second picture
appears. That looks kind of horrible. Let's have a closer look on how we can
make this look nicer. First of all, let's move the rocket a little bit, and
let's make the red planet a bit smaller. Well, that's much nicer. But it's a
bit tedious to do this with your hands and with clicking and clicking, that's
where programming comes in. Here I've written a program that does the same
actions, that you've just seen me do by clicking in a java program, a step at a
time. We'll understand all of the details pretty soon, but let me show you the
basic lay of the land. We're making a picture out of the mariner4 image, we're
translating it, we're drawing it, we're making another picture object, we're
shrinking it and we're drawing it, and that composes the picture. Now when you
operate in this way, you make an object and then you later need to do something
to that object. And it's, it's in a program here, it's not in the BlueJ work
bench. And then it becomes very important to give names to each of the
pictures. You'll notice I call this one rocket. I call this one planet. Those
names are names of variables, and that what we're want to discuss next.